taking a trip from New York to
Washington in a metal tube at 700
miles-per-hour sounds a bit like science
fiction but could your seat on the
Hyperloop be arriving sooner than you
think this week SpaceX founder Elon Musk
issued a provocative tweet saying he's
received verbal government approval to
build the system here to talk about it
Tim Stevens editor at large at CNET's
Roadshow which covers transportation
technology Tim good morning good morning
how realistic is this it's still pretty
early days as far as we can tell those
conversations were with the White House
a white house representative said they'd
had positive conversations that's pretty
far from actual verbal approval mayor de
Blasio's office here in New York said
this was the first time they actually
heard of it when a story broke so we
stood a long way to go so tell us a
little bit more about this what would
this entail the basic idea is to create
a low pressure series of tubes that go
underground running from New York City
to Washington DC and because they're low
pressure you can put a basically train
inside of them and without wind
resistance they can go over 700 miles an
hour which would get us there in under
30 minutes versus now you know a couple
hours at least where is the technology
on this right now still very early the
technology is progressing though we're
seeing some demonstrations that are
starting to get there various companies
are starting to compete it's almost
becoming like an underground space race
where various companies are trying to
one-up each other and get there faster
one company called Hyperloop one has
demonstrated a system that actually
works but thus far they've only gotten
up to about 70 miles an hour so we still
have sort of a long way to go I'm sorry
what about Hyperloop plans where would
those be
so the Hyperloop is basically this this
overall concept for this technology Elon
Musk kind of ideated the idea put it out
there and then basically gave the idea
out there it's anybody to develop the
launch they basically kind of open
sourced it so now there's this
competition going where multiple
companies are trying to develop this
technology sooner than anybody else and
bring it to market sooner than anybody
else you mentioned Hyperloop 1 which has
actually tested a prototype in the
Nevada Nevada desert right yeah
absolutely so we've seen a couple
demonstrations from them and they've
actually created a closed loop system so
they're really getting pretty far along
but the problems here aren't so much the
technology they're more to do with
regulation and getting the permission
for land use rights for example actually
build these things we've seen so many
systems high-speed train systems and
tall systems have been shut down by
environmental studies and things like
that and there's a long way to go on
that front when
say long way to go maybe this is tough
to do but so what are we looking at is
this in our lifetime that we might see
it well I mean one of the closest
apparel is we can look at here in New
York is the Hudson tunnel project which
has been going on for decades now and
that needs to go about two miles
underneath the Hudson River that's the
cost there's expected to be about eleven
billion dollars or more and again it's
been going on for decades must wants to
go 200 miles between New York City and
DC so the cost you've got a figure it's
going to be some exponent on top of that
and the amount of time the land use
regulations that's a huge problem to get
through the Hyperloop isn't the only
transportation system must gives
developing is it I mean he's working on
he wants an underground auto system
Mosca's got a lot of great ideas a lot
of crazy ideas a lot of you to kind of
borrowed from science fiction which is
great to see - so the Hyperloop was
actually a technology that was ideated
hundreds of years ago but Muska also
wants to create this underground series
of tunnels for cars the idea of being
you'd park in a special parking area
your car would gracefully drop below the
surface and then it would enter this
series of tunnels it would be shut along
to where you want to go and then when
you get there it would pop right up and
you'd be at your destination no traffic
to worry about want to work really bad I
do too but you know in the future of
autonomous cars that you have to wonder
do you really even need cars in the
situation if you can just drop you up
where you need to go maybe you can just
put you outside your building the
reality here you say autonomous cars I'm
thinking we've talked about flying cars
as well I mean what is that is it above
ground is it flying in the sky what is
our next resource that it's definitely
gonna be a combination of all those
things that's pretty exciting to think
about what that's going to look like but
autonomy is coming much more quickly
than we think I mean we see there's a
Volvo has self-driving cars in Sweden
right now that you can buy and we're
seeing a lot of private programs here in
the US and Tesla of course another Elon
Musk company is doing a lot of great
research on autonomy - that's all coming
really really quickly and it's really
exciting to see Tim Stevens thank you
very much thank you